there should be a good spot it's a high
traffic area 1920 of exhaust and
therefore plenty of platinum all right
let's get you up
[Music]
you ain't gonna help
[Music]
it'd be faster if you helped well we
know that's not happening the powder
again because the Platinum particles are
extremely small sometimes no more than
just a few atoms if I was as far as you
I play the stock market we're going
process dry I'd rather spend my time
focusing on important things like
figuring out how the universe works
so say you figure out how the universe
works then what I'm not sure but in the
mean time I agree with Richard Fineman I
simply enjoy the pleasure of finding
things out Tiger with the Beastie Boys
you gotta fight for your right to party
well it's good to have a personal
philosophy what's next we create a
chemical flux by combining borax sodium
carbonate lead oxide and flour
you know Sheldon George you are working
on something together that's nice and
guess what Missy asked me if she could
wear a cross she's in her bedroom saying
prayers right now hmm well what are you
talking about our kids are behaving
exactly something Bad's gonna happen
why can't you just be thankful because
that's when life kicks you right in the
plums marry dad where's your power drill
why our oven doesn't reach 2,000 degrees
so we're going to make a homemade kiln
out of a garbage can and they're gonna
plant are you two trying to burn down
the house no we're trying to make
platinum out of gravel you're not
building a 2,000 degree oven fine just
so you know I was gonna cut you in
you'll fight very to party but not for
your right to make a device that'll
exceed the melting point of lead
[Music]
what's your problem mom and dad won't
let me build a kiln so Georgie I can't
finish her experiment before you tell me
I don't care to kiln us
okay but you'll never know it's a
high-temperature oven you're unhappy
just ask God for help I don't believe in
God
Shh he can hear you he knows if you've
been bad or good like Santa he can send
you to hell
I'm not going to ask some magical being
to solve my problems I asked him to help
me with my batting and he dead
there's a pottery kiln in art class we
can use that good job but that does not
count as one of my wishes